smith's food and drugstore the sponsor
of this segment has been on the front
lines to ensure everyone has access to
the food services and products they need
during this unprecedented pandemic
september is hunger action month and we
have smith chief and we have smith chef
jeff and adriana martindale from smith's
corporate affairs to tell us more
hello everybody i'm chef jeffrey smith
today is a special day i have a my
special friend abriana why are you here
today you know september is hunger
action month and that's our favorite
month in september because it's all
about making sure people have access to
fresh food so today we're using
something a little different when it
comes to jeff's recipe so what are we
cooking today so today i'm making just a
really quick beef chili with black beans
but what's special about this recipe is
that i'm using food that's
i guess you could say rescued it's food
that's near it's it's it's expiration uh
produce that's near and what's cool
about smith is they have these uh you've
probably seen them before these reduced
stickers that's what they do to stuff
that's getting near its its date um and
it's just a great way to save money but
it's also a great way to use up that
food that may otherwise be thrown away
so it's really kind of cool that way so
at smith's we have a social strategy
called zero hunger zero waste so we do
our best to eliminate food waste across
all of our operations to help and hunger
so jeff just talked about food rescue
that's something you'll see right here
this is perfect produce that may have a
few blemishes but is still nutritious
and still human consumable so we want to
make sure that we're not throwing this
away and sometimes we just need to
change our perspective on how we can use
this produce
one in five children don't know where
their next meal is coming from so if
there's a child who hasn't had an apple
in a week we can easily just skim off
some of this peel and use it in a recipe
like you're doing here right for sure or
just use it all together i mean
you know what a banana that's brown is a
better banana than one that's not you
know what i mean so it's just that that
mentality of the they don't have to look
perfect to be healthy or even delicious
so
right so there's some other things that
we can do at home to savor food one
thing that we can do is meat so it's
surprising to know that expiration dates
aren't regulated right
those dates are just put forth by our
vendors saying that's potentially peak
quality so what do we do when we want to
taste that food yeah so if you've got
some of this reduced meat that you get
from the meat department throw it in
your freezer and it can last for up to
four to six months so
you're using a product that you get for
cheaper and you're not throwing it away
you're saving it it'd be perfectly fine
in your freezer for six months i
actually had a gallon of milk the other
day
that i was using
10 days past its desperation and it was
still
perfectly fine right so those expiration
dates doesn't mean that the food has
gone bad use your senses give it a
little taste test right usually it can
go past those days smells exactly freeze
it on the expiration date you can also
freeze milk on its expiration date and
it can last months longer so thank you
jeff thank you for helping us eliminate
hunger in our communities and you can
always make a difference at smith's
different smiths by rounding up to the
next dollar at any register and all of
those funds get donated to your local
food banks so look at this chili so this
is my chili we use the the food that was
almost expiring and it looks delightful
right we're gonna dig right into that i
also was able to find some discounted
muffin mix so there you have it thank
you guys so much for watching and thank
you for shopping we will see you all
next time bye-bye
thank you to smith's food and drug for
sponsoring this segment visit them
online at smithfoodanddrug.com for more